J'aime quand-même prendre cet
exemple des chasses traditionnelles
que charlorie a souligné
tout à l'heure.
La même scène,
tourner dans le fond de l'Amazonie,
projeter à la télévision le dimanche après-midi,
nous arracher des larmes à tous les bonbons européens.
Ils trouveraient tout ça formidable. Alors quoi ?
Parce qu'on est des Gaulois ?
Genre, des Gaulois refractaires, c'est vrai,
mais on en est fier d'être des Gaulois refractaires
alors, parce que c'est chez nous,
c'est pas bien.
Moi, j'ai des amis qui disent, ouais, mais bon,
faudrait peut-être qu'on laisse
partir quelques morceaux de la chasse
française ou de la pêche,
je leur dis, vous vous trompez,
l'Europe ne veut pas moins de chasse,
elle veut plus de chasse.
L'Europe ne veut pas moins de tradition.
L'Europe ne veut plus de tradition.
C'est toujours beaucoup plus
facile de manier 1 peuple qui sait plus d'où il vient,
quand il faut,
quand on veut l'amener exactement où on veut.
L'Europe ne veut pas moins de passion,
elle ne veut plus de passion.
L'Europe ne veut pas moins de ruralité,
elle ne veut plus de ruralité.
L'Europe, aujourd'hui théocratique comme elle est-elle,
ne veut plus de liberté ?
Alors si vous croyez encore à tout ça,
ah ben il est pas trop tard.
Le neuf/06, votez, parlez-en autour de vous,
la rivalité peut encore gagner,
vous pouvez encore avoir 1 espoir,
le droit d'être libre et d'espérer.